good to see you Hank good to see you
what's going on having to rich oh good
to see kept could just put one within
three feet on the first off there we go
I have met ninth I have them at nine to
one is that really yeah you do 9:01 that
obviously a pre-tournament right Hank
yeah okay well what else you got on this
on this a championship anything that's
your only ticket I played that Patrick
however you say his name but he's
1-under he finishes second round okay
very good
all right Hank let's get to it right
here before we get to the Preakness
what'd you think of that finish do you
think that was a rightful DQ of maximum
size yeah you did yeah okay yeah I
thought he had to come down I I was on
the air at the time and I said before
Belmont said it if this was the third
race that's your favorite local
racetrack he would have come down within
five minutes I think that the decision
that I don't agree would was was
suspending sires
for fifteen days I think he did whatever
he could to avoid an accident and did a
good job of restoring that horse so that
there was no accident and CIA actually
should be praised for for avoiding any
further trouble in the wrist and he's
going to appeal that III hope he wins
that those stewards I agree with what
they did although I don't know why they
had it be a claim of foul you know they
should have put you know they should
have put it in as a problem before that
and then why it took them 40 minutes to
make a decision Yeah right
I didn't understand that either well
what do you think of a idea of a lawsuit
by maximum security the owners of
maximum security Hank I wouldn't bet on
them and I mean how many kind of times
can they disqualify this horse right
there's there's no chance of that right
don't you convenient prove now I wonder
how what is the etiquette of handicap
here Hank do you go up to Bill Mont and
say to him how come you didn't you know
whisper in my ear about you know the
long shot to win country house why don't
you whisper about that do you do that I
don't think he expected to win the race
with that horse and that amazing you
know he really liked you know his other
horse who you know who was you know he
liked who we had really trained up to
that race and you know the race was a
fluke it was written you know it was run
terrible conditions there was a lot of a
lot of bumping around going on because
of the track being so gooey and the
horses were hitting each other through
the hole through the whole race and his
horse in fact that the one who he like
got knocked around plenty and he ran a
big race considering all the difficulty
yeah denied I think the Belmont will be
interesting okay well let's get to the
Preakness right here Hank the hammer
Goldberg on the Rich Eisen show is this
an amount of horses for the Preakness it
seems like so but you you would
obviously have a letter okay
yeah usually a lot of a lot of horses a
lot of horsemen passed on a freak news
coming out of the Derby which happened
again but because the field is not
supposed to be as tough this year a lot
of horses entered and there's 13 horses
in but you know horses but this was an
odd year and that there were a few
horses who were the break or two could
have been in a Kentucky Derby but didn't
have enough points and some of them are
in this race and one of them I like a
lot okay all right I like it all right
let's get into it who do you like a loss
in this Preakness
I like bourbon war I talked to his
trainer mark henick yesterday
mark and I are good friends and I called
him he got right back to me this is a
horse that ran and the Fountain of Youth
and he was second and he's a
closer and he was running on a speed
favouring track and he grant forth in
the Florida Derby and he was just beaten
out of the third spot by code of honor
who ran a big race in the Kentucky Derby
and you know hit the board but and if
this worse had gotten a little bit of a
better started his move a little earlier
he would have beaten code of honor on a
speed favouring track and you know he
course you know maximum security won
that race with as long speed and he
should like the extra distance in this
race and talking with with mark he's
told me that he's making a little slight
adjust adjustment equipment adjustment
with what they call short-term blinkers
so that the horse will make his move a
little earlier he's got a war of will a
way of will rather and warriors charged
on either side of him both of whom were
going to go for the lead early which
will create a lot of room for Max's our
verbal war excuse me hmm and he should
get a real smooth trip and ideal trip
from the to post okay and and this horse
he's training great right now and he's
as good as any horses that ran in the
Derby based on his performance on speed
favoring tracks in Florida and he say
should get the best of it because
there's a lot of speed ministration well
I like that's up for him I like the odds
of 12 to 1 right now as you and I are
talking yeah he won't be 12 to 1 after
ridiculous
okay that guy made a bad line and when
you get a bad line in football you go
for it and this was a bad line and I
should be five or six to one and you
know the trainer agrees with me there's
no way I think he's going to get bet
okay I don't think he'll be 12 to 1 at
post time but but I like him so much I
never bet horses to win I'm betting this
horse to win all right
that is a very high praise quality
endorsement from the hammer all right
then how else do we fill out a ticket
exactas trifectas supers Wow let me out
here how do I want to say I want to sign
I want to sign her today
give me a signer I just that's all I
want you know all right you ready yeah
I'm ready I should have given you the
signer the last race oh my gosh dad
where is this post wanting you remember
but I didn't put them on top good could
you imagine it well it's always $0.50
what's a 50 grand right for this super
ya derby or grand gosh but anyway it's
interesting I talking with some of the
trainers they horse they think may be
the one to beat his Owen Dale post five
okay he's ten to one okay he beat
another twist of fate who's six to one
that is well posed we've got a bad post
and he lost all when Dale in a race who
that was running Kentucky oh and Al is
it was a Louisville Lexington stakes set
three starts this year and he's won
twice and he's got the right kind of
style and he's and he's getting good at
the right time okay I think you have to
use improbable because he's the class of
the race and although yeah I remember
talking to Elliot Waldman from when
stark
about possible distance limitations for
this horse and he said that because the
sire side would suggest that and he said
this horse wouldn't have distance
limitations well the race he ran into
therapy would indicate that he does that
he couldn't make the mile and a quarter
he was in good position he just didn't
fire and stretch so I'm putting him
probable in because I think you have to
use him he's Baffert who and all seven
previous that he that he won the horses
came out of the Derby okay and then
there's another horse in here called
always mining hmm who is six for six
this year is
six races all of them were run at one
track Borel he won the Tessio and he
came from a little bit off the pace
normally he's on the lead but I would
put him in there because in talking with
a couple of trainers in fact talking
with with the trainer of Bourbon war I
asked him about other horses he said he
looked at film of always mining he said
that's a good horse okay so what do you
got for me here that don't we scare it
off by the fact that he's only won at
one track okay and remember the Tesio
used to be run at Pimlico
but the only weren't run twelve races a
year now a film ago so this will be his
first race over that track so I'm going
to use the two with the five to seven
and and the floor okay so if it comes to
five seven you're gonna have a signer
okay yeah alright so your your best
exacta is what two five bourbon war and
Owen Dale yes okay and if you want to
throw in one more worse okay who will
give you the bomb it's a warrior's
charge who's who's only who was never
run in the stakes race but he's two for
two races at Oaklawn and he won his last
by twelve and a half lanes and he's got
a ton of speed okay and he may you know
he may hold on for a piece okay so your
best exact is two five and if you're
doing a try you wanna if you have to
throw improbable two five four right
yeah and then two five seven two five
seven okay very good which is always
money thank you thank you the best man I
am mandated ask you as we go out the
door right here the Tessio is that named
after the a Bogota character from The
Godfather
thank know I you know says I'm it that
was a mistake that they made because
Tesio was the guy who who ratted out
remember Michael the race to come in he
was loyal there you go you're right
you know Tessa as you note SEO asked
Frank Hagin to be let off the hook
for old times sake didn't work out
spoiler alert you know you know one time
it's all times safe that's why we're
gonna win this race one time for old
we'll chat with you in a couple weeks
thankful chat soon okay right you the
man that's the hammer Hank over four
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app